jean martineau monsois bonsoir du à
double jeu quand il évoque les souvenirs
que tu viens d'évoquer avec roger pierre
s'atténue dans quel état 7 mais non ça
m'émeut pas sam sam
ça m'amuse ça me fait rire parce qu'avec
roger puis on a patrie quand même 40
années à se marrer beaucoup c'était un
peu tout le programme dans la nuit et
pourquoi vous êtes séparés on s'est
séparé en 75 pour pour deux raisons la
première c'est que on en avait un tout
petit peu à s'en remettre au travail et
où on peut être trop de télé autre chose
en parka de chez nous le matin à 7h ans
après à 2h ou 3h du matin on était crevé
et on s'amusait plus de la même façon à
jouer alors on a trouvé que c'était un
petit peu mal honnête vis-à-vis du
public de pas ne pas être heureux de
jouer
puis on s'est dit aussi un jour les gens
vont penser qu'on est vraiment d'offres
2 deux frères siamois que l'on n'a qu'un
seul cerveau pour deux
il faut aussi qu il est juste temps de
faire encore quelques choses séparément
quitte à se retrouver après on s'y
retrouvait après avec beaucoup de joie
quand on est maintenant sur trop de
temps en temps avec toujours autant de
joie mais ça c'est un peu la version
ceci reste qu'à paris nice après une
dispute à ce moment-là ça ça me plairait
bien à pas non non je suis désolé
frustré d'études ça plaisait beaucoup de
journalistes
on a tout eu 10 km et 2 qui était malade
là on a dit que
une femme nous avait séparés enfin tout
foutu mais c'est pas vrai
malheureusement que c'est pas vrai je
voudrais bien de faire plaisir mais
est-ce que tu crois pas qu'il a plus
souffert que toi de la séparation temps
mais bon je comprends maintenant vite eu
tout de suite tourné mon oncle
d'amérique d'alain resnais avec alain
renner non on a eu de la non on a eu du
pot même je dois dire en 84 quand tu a
rempilé avec lui c'était un petit peu
pour lui donner un coup de main ou
c'était passeront donc pour luth l'aï
donc c'était parce qu'on en a eu envie
non là l'idée était la suivante en est
tous les deux deux fils qui est jamais
d'autres enfin le plus jeune avec semble
figé avec ce pays voisin ce qui est lui
son fils jean françois nous
connaissaient pas n'avaient pas vu ce
qu'ont - alors on s'est dit c'est quand
même vachement mieux la connaissent pas
ce qu'on a fait on a refait ce spectacle
un peu pour eux et vos relations
l'époque était uniquement professionnel
amical sexuelle et 20 sexuelle
j'ajouterai qu'à un moment tu poseras
cette question je regrette et je
regrette finalement qu'on n'ait pas été
au mot tous les deux parce que qu'est ce
qu'on aurait fait comme un ami de tous
bords les chambres d'hôtel on met
malheureusement fait je suis désolé non
ici c'est pas marrant de venir ici quand
et nip et d une ivrogne nitro et on va
trouver une telle pratique et dans
l'intimité vous appeliez comment roro et
jeanjean